hey this is press tow
Walker this is an interesting question
that appeared in a comic strip a man has
20 coins consisting of dimes and
quarters a dime is a currency that is
equal to 10 cents and a quarter is a
currency that's equal to 25
cents if the dimes were quarters and the
quarters were dimes he would have 90
cents more than he has now
how many dimes and quarters does he
have this is adapted from a Peanuts
comic strip and I thank Brandon for the
suggestion pause the video if you'd like
to give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve this
[Music]
problem
I will first present a numerical
solution so we've opened up a
spreadsheet and I've copied over the
problem so we have all the
information we'll start out by writing a
column with the total number of coins
this is equal to
20 then we have the number of Dimes and
the number of
quarters so let's just say the number of
Dimes will start out at zero we're going
to increase this for all the possible
cases the number of quarters will be
equal to the total number of coins minus
the number of
Dimes we also want to see how much money
does the person have
initially so the amount of money in
cense will be equal to 10times the
number of Dimes plus 25 * the number of
quarters so 20 quarters time 25 will be
equal to 500
cents now what happens in the swap case
that is when the dimes were quarters and
the quarters were dimes so the new
number of Dimes and the new number of
quarters will be equal to the swap of
the original so the new number of Dimes
will be equal to the old number of
quarters and the new number of quarters
Dimes the amount of money in this case
will be the same exact equation so we
can just copy this formula over it'll be
equal to the number of Dimes * 10 plus
the number of quarters * 25 we can just
go ahead and make sure the formula
copied
correctly now we want to know the
difference between the new amount of
money and the old amount of money so we
take the new amount of money and we
subtract out the old amount of money
right now this is negative 300 because
the person has 300 cents less than
initial
now each time the total number of coins
will be equal to
20 the number of Dimes we can increase
this will go between 0o and 20 so we'll
take this and we'll add one then all the
remaining formulas will copy the number
of quarters will be equal to the total
minus the number of Dimes then all the
other formulas will calculate
correctly so there we go so we need to
consider all possible cases
is the number of Dimes can be a whole
number from 0 to 20 so we'll just
patiently copy down all of the different
possibilities now we need to see where
the difference is exactly equal to 90
cents so in this case we look at this
row this means that the person had 13
dimes and seven quarters to begin with
and that's the way you can solve it
numerically
now I just want to illustrate one more
method let's say you didn't want to put
all of these rows out we had just set up
this formula in the first row you can
also solve it using the goal seek
function so go to data what if analysis
and goal seek now we want to make the
difference equal to+ 90 and we will
change the number of
Dimes so we go ahead and say go ahead
and do this let's see what you can get
it's going to calculate some value and
it will give us the
solution so we get 13 dimes and seven
quarters now let's solve the problem
algebraically step by step a man has 20
coins consisting of dimes and
quarters let D be a variable to
represent the number of Dimes and Q be a
variable to represent the number of
quarters this sentence translates into
into the equation D + Q is equal to
20 how much money does the man have in
cents each dime is worth 10 cents and
each quarter is worth 25 cents so the
amount of money the man starts with is
10 * D + 25 *
Q if the dimes were quarters and the
quarters were dimes he would have 90
cents more than he has now so how much
money would he have if dimes were
quarters and quarters were dimes we need
to exchange the variables D and Q so
that we get the amount of money he would
have so this will be equal to 10 Q +
25d now we need to take this amount of
money and subtract the original amount
of money we get a resulting equation so
10 Q minus 25 Q will be equal to -5 Q
then 25d - 10d is equal to +
15D the difference in money will be
equal to 90 cents more so this is equal
to 90 cents as a positive
number so we just need to solve for the
variables D and
Q so we now have two equations in two
variables to simplify this we'll take
the equation and divide both sides of
the equation by 15 so we get Q + D now
we need to divide 90 by 15 so the way I
think about it is I count up so I go 15
30 45 60 75 and 90 so that's six times
so 90 / 15 is 6 so we get ne Q + D is
equal to
6 we can now take this equation and
compare it to to the first equation well
we've ended up in a lucky situation we
have a plus Q here and a negative Q here
so if we add the two equations we will
eliminate the Q variable so we end up
with 2D is equal to
26 dividing through by two means that D
is equal to 13 now the number of Dimes
plus the number of quarters is equal to
20 so 13 + Q is equal to 20 and that
means the number of quarters is equal to
seven so the man has 13 dimes and seven
quarters and that's the
answer thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time